nearly any move here's winnie for black  maybe use one of the rooks to capture  the bishop i would use the rook on the f  line  to keep complete control to box in black  uh keep the white king caged  okay he checks with the pawn the king  has to step back  um along the diagonal because if it  steps up and captures a pawn then that  would be checkmate  in a couple of turns so okay the white  king trying to survive but  that can simply capture the bishop  either way now and it should be  checkmate in a few moves  wow um yep there we go  black is strengthening to check with the  pawn and give mate so magnus resigns  it's over magnus carlsen losing the  second game  on day two of the semi-final and this  means huge drama for the world champion  he now has to